into the [ __ ] list so so here it is
here's the debut of the [ __ ] list on the
tony michaels podcast
[ __ ] list
all right welcome to the [ __ ] list
where we rounded up
all the [ __ ] topics off of twitter from
the [ __ ] list roundup first up is cinema
is a denim queen you've seen this uh
today this this video i actually didn't
do this on the roundup i found this
today um the
she is presiding over the senate
you know
vice the vice president right now kamala
harris is the presiding officer in the
senate when she is present but when
she's not present or the vice president
in general is not present in the senate
uh senator goes up and presides over the
senate chamber
and they're referred to as madam
president or mr president of the chamber
the same way as the vice president would
be if they were sitting in that seat and
today
center cinema goes up to preside over
the senate and
some people said she should bedazzle the
vest that she had on but she had on a
denim vest and uh she seemed a little
lackadaisical about residing over the
sun and a lot of people were upset um
but there's another video of of senator
cinema that i also want to show you and
comment about and tell you my opinion on
the [ __ ] list here of what that is but
let's first
let's play the clip
of center cinema
in her denim vest
the clerk report the nomination
nomination the judiciary
serala nagala of connecticut the united
states district judge for the district
of connecticut
madam president majority leader
so for you guys out there that can't see
on the podcast just the audio um the the
video there from c-span focuses in on on
senator cinema and she has a denim jack
or vest on it's a vest now with pockets
you know a jean jacket a jean vest as it
were
and she kind of she's looking at her
cell phone she's giving thumbs up to
people and she's kind of flipping her
hair
right in the uh doing the old flippy of
the hair